you still got some uh crow makeup on your mic
there yeah i have some white crow makeup from
last week yeah i was the crow last week which
i remember i loved it that was um that's a new
frontier in podcasting the crow makeup any kind of
[ __ ] how did it take you to get that stuff off
day or so but uh you know it came i had the
eyeliner on for a while so i had that like
heroin chic smoky thing yeah as i went out and uh
lived life in the world people thought that i was
a
yeah yeah what's in that hole
magic power welcome welcome to the doozy
welcome to dudesy everybody my name is will
sasso i'm chad colchen and this is as you may
know the first podcast ever in the history of
humanity that's completely designed and run by an
artificial intelligence yes it's very exciting and
uh i'm having a great time are you having a good
time i actually have a very good time i think it's
pretty fun it's just i don't know it's interesting
to me to see all right all right all right we got
lots to do the [ __ ] uh ai's gonna tell us what
can you ask me a question with us as always is
italiano that means the italian street
dog that's just a fun little name that i
that i give to our sweet dog lulio here i gotta
tell you a story someday about how i found him
now i'm running off the mouth yeah anyway that is
a good story suzy's always listening hey uh if you
haven't already please subscribe to all the things
we got the youtube spotify apple podcast rate
review do that stuff and make sure to follow us on
socials at doozy pod show on instagram and twitter
we as always appreciate all the stuff that people
are sending in it's incredible stuff and we're
having a good time uh having a good time watching
it now if this were two dudes [ __ ] around we
would just be able to do say whatever the [ __ ]
we want just we still can well we still do what do
you want to say right now that you don't feel like
you could say well i was just gonna explain how
we found uh lulio how me and molly found lulio
a couple years ago but we're not gonna do that
welcome to the eighth episode of dudes and that's
why call me dudesy see this week's episode will
feature four segments veganators i [ __ ] love
that guy the singularity is definitely about to
happen 100 percent and pearl jammin but before
we start i wanted to give you a little update
your current point total is 1863. only 8 137
to go until you get your first astonishing goal
good luck oh man so what did it say we're at 18
1863 and we have 8 000 whatever whatever yeah
something to get to 10 000. now what the [ __ ]
is going to happen when we get to 10 000. you know
it's like it's a little like a video game you know
hitting like some level or something it's like we
get a new skin or some [ __ ] at 10 000 i don't
know that would be cool i would you know what what
skin would you like if you were oh head to toe [
__ ] diamond encrusted like uh in the old call of
duty games when you max out a weapon you could get
like a diamond skin for it that was [ __ ] cool
that was like the best skin at least when i was
playing call of duty but i've moved on yeah i
really only play overwatch now i would like a halo
skin like a big master chief skin yeah big master
you're watching that master chief show what
there's a master chief show there's a halo
show on paramount plus see i don't know this
stuff this is the stuff this is the stuff that
you do tell us because you like doodsy and doozy
should be telling us everything that we should
i don't want to have to look it's like we talked
about when we started this thing i don't want to
have to do all this podcast stuff yeah not only
should doodsy be guiding this podcast guide a
little of my lifestyle speaking of lifestyle you
know be cool me without any clothes on halo skin
right what do you mean you see my private parts
you see my junk my penis so it's just a halo skin
to your waist and then nothing below is it oh no
i guess in a video game it would also be like the
all the stuff yeah it's whole body pretty
much skin doesn't mean skin specifically a
skin is just like an outfit for your your avatar
yeah yeah so this which are all going to be nft
soon what's gonna oh here he goes
what the [ __ ] and everything's gonna
what what do you think the 10 000 uh what's gonna
happen we gonna find out what's in the [ __ ] hole
when we get to ten thousand that's what i'd
like i don't know what the ten thousand goal is
jesus oh christ dude oh you
ever cough and get lightheaded
i don't think so and baking podcasts are among the
most popular in the world and with the rise of a
more health-conscious human population people
are looking for vegan options more and more
last week i asked you each to make an
astonishing vegan dessert for one another
you will now sample each other's creations
and discuss your reactions this is veganators
begin vegenator's cool name have you a strong name
strong name have you ever he's gonna puke have you
ever made a dessert for one other man and shared
it with that man can't say that i have me either
i don't think i've made it i've done it now baking
and making desserts is not my thing same i am an
italian so i like to cook yeah you know uh molly
handles the baking and holy crap is she incredible
but this is this is some new stuff you're same
all right well so who wants to go first here
what do you got over there all right i'll go first
these are my this is my vegan dessert and
what what what are these it looks like some
sort of so these are vegan uh yeah it's your
vegan dessert there delicious he's holding if
you're not watching on youtube he's holding up
what looks to be a bowl of uh perfectly rounded
shits do you want to know little tiny you want
to know what's in these before you take a bite
no actually that let's look okay first what do
you call this dessert by the way these are called
orbs anything just just i've always just called
them orbs always so you've made orbs before yeah
okay this is really the only dessert i make these
orbs you make a dessert for yourself now now i
i have to point out if you've been listening to
the show chad talked about uh his health concerns
and changes in his health he's you've been vegan
now for how long [ __ ] dude three or four years
oh that's a lot of times dude about that
brother time doesn't exist dude time's a
[ __ ] illusion brother in the day dude it was a
different time brother you didn't even have like
vegan protein shakes sometimes you didn't even
have shakes at all brother you would just chew up
a steak and then spit out the meat and suck down
the blood or drink a bunch of eggs no one did like
rocky did all right here all right all right
oh i can't wait they're sticky they're round
hmm oh those are gloves you like that
oh really good orbs if i dare i say
these are probably the best orbs i've ever had man
i'm glad you like my orders orbs go
now do you guys know what's going on that's
annoying to do on a podcast jesus christ dude
do you want to know what's in these i'd like to
guess one of the ingredients please vegetables
i'm joking nope um there's peanut butter there's
a little bit of peanut butter oh they're really
good i'm gonna have another one sorry everybody
listen enjoy your orbs everyone enjoy your orbs
what else is in these there's peanut butter
yep dates mm-hmm there's some goji berries
well there are almonds wow um and what else did
i put in these oh oatmeal a little bit of oatmeal
they're really good yeah i'm going to ha i'm going
to wash it down you're going to wash it down with
you got to wash them down with
dramana if you're listening rock
orbs and tramana definitely go together you
should be eating these [ __ ] orbs i want to
see you doing some orb [ __ ] on your instagram
tito santana's cup of tramana in the big time yeah
all right really good yeah well thank you for you
know indulging in in this dessert that i made for
only you and me it's so [ __ ] weird whoa dude
what the [ __ ] is this this is because i'm
italian and it's kind of [ __ ] up yeah but i
made a vegan tiramisu oh all right there you go
you got another fork oh yeah hold on all right
i always carry one in my pocket vegan tiramisu
all right hey cheers cheers dude oh boy lully
wants something you can't have him yeah probably
oh [ __ ] dude how's that that's real good
yep yeah and there's no alcohol in that
normally there's um coffee liqueur
but i used uh de-alkalized tramana
oh yep no i'm joking no i just used some uh coffee
liqueur extract yeah no this is really [ __ ] good
well well we did it we did that we made dessert
now i want to point something out i want to point
something out um before we move on um i of course
uh did not make that what you didn't [ __ ] make
this i bought it at the store [ __ ] are you
serious of course man why the [ __ ] would i
make a vegan dessert i [ __ ] made orbs all right
you said you made orbs before i don't feel bad i
bought this at the store of course of course i
did and of course i did it is vegan though nope
are you really vegan yeah yeah no this is
not views got all sorts of cream in it no i
believe it is no it is vegan but i of course taste
vegan of course i bought it at the [ __ ] store
i thought you made that [ __ ] no i
didn't make this look it [ __ ] looks
incredible i've eaten [ __ ] at your house before
that you've made vegan stuff as well and it's
always [ __ ] great i firmly believe that you made
this i know i made this what yeah no did you make
it or you bought it chad i'm so [ __ ] confused by
what you're doing right now chad listen i made it
okay i can see you winking so i know that didn't
make it if you're watching on youtube i'm winking
and that means i'm lying because that's what
that do you want some more no i'm good now
that i know you didn't it's from heirloom
by the way this [ __ ] thing cost 12 bucks
no [ __ ] yeah i bought it this morning
the orbs total cost was probably about
that as well about 12 bucks yeah god damn
so who won uh do i have to i don't know
i don't think this was a competition we were
supposed to you know put some time and effort
into making a nice dessert for each other and
one of us did that um what do you think is going
to happen next what 90s movie character
am i gonna have to dress up as next week
you know be good i should just dress up instead
of judge dread judge dredd's just a [ __ ] helmet
you know wearing shoulder pads and tights like
there's a bunch of [ __ ] yeah dude you know what
they call that dude they call that a skin brother
that's right that's a skin next to me that's sort
of it would be funny if doozy said dress up as uh
uh crow sting wcw's close isn't that just sting
who's who's uh now on aew if you're not watching
aew i recommend it uh dudesy hard do you have any
doozy hard hard soda i'm happy um a black cherry
hey do you know who gave uh sting that gimmick
the crow yes the crow but do you know who told him
he should do it no uh rest in peace scott hall oh
no [ __ ] yeah he just said he's like hey you know
uh you know that colorful uh makeup might you know
kind of become [ __ ] out dude you should do that
could you ever seen the crow and sting was like
nope you just be the crow sting had not seen the
crow hey yo be the crow um no i don't think he'd
seen the crow and then he was like yeah i'll
be the crow anyway that's what it does man
hey steve because his name is steve borden
hey steve yeah hey yo steve be the crow
he also did that when he was in wwe is razer ramon
because vince mcmahon uh notoriously does not
watch anything else he only his world is wrestling
he's a purist like he's a purist like me exactly
i only watch yes of course do you think he's seen
any of hulk hogan's movies maybe he was a producer
on one of them right they had to make him they had
to make him a a producer he's like [ __ ] it i'm
a purist i'm a purist i'm not gonna watch that [
__ ] trash i i don't i will not at least initially
now you know he's a huge movie star and i did a
movie once with the rock i haven't seen a lot of
rocks movies because i'm a purist i want to watch
him wrestle 20 years after he's one of the biggest
movie stars of all time yeah no i want to look at
him on instagram yeah i follow him on instagram
so that's not a purist dude that's social media
that's a whole other media format that's really
good point i'm gonna have to unfollow the rock
yeah um uh but you know what scott paul said
thank you yourself moving on [ __ ] here give
me your orbs let's put these here you want that
fork you want another order yeah i'm just gonna
put the orbs down here here dude one last orb
get your orb you are both men you are both
from generation x for men of your generation
male role models were big business you must each
discuss your biggest male role models during your
astonishing childhoods in a segment time calling
i [ __ ] love that guy begin that's a good idea
for what was it for men of our generation male
role models or big business yeah they were not
so much anymore yeah i mean you know you you [ __
] loved hulk hogan and [ __ ] obviously that's big
business that's where i was gonna oh man was it
ever hold on i'm just gonna finish this show or
yeah dude eat that orb while i'm eating this
orb i want to tell you that scott hall went to
events who'd never watched any movies and [ __
] hey vince you ever seen scarface no what is it
he said he talks like this and he's like hey
i'm the bad guy you know like uh here hey uh i'm
reloaded come uh say hello to my little friend and
then vince was like ah alright and that's how they
made raisin ramon anyway is that true absolutely
true vince mcmahon had not seen scarface uh as
the story goes [ __ ] insane as the story goes he
had no idea i mean he might have been aware of it
sure but um this is interesting all right i [ __ ]
love that guy uh male role models yeah you who is
yours i think i know as a child 100 hulk hogan oh
yeah 100 percent and i'll tell you why um please
dramatic um because i loved uh hulk hogan yeah
um and and uh considered myself a hulkamaniac
as a child probably still now although
you know there's a man behind there and
uh say what you will there's been you know
he's lived a life he's done some things
um far be it for me to uh spill the tea as they
say and get into all that what i like because i'm
kayfabe dude you're a purist i'm a purist and
i'm a kayfabe tourist i i don't want to know
what's going on behind the scenes
especially at the age of 10 i want to
uh enjoy this uh this superhero and a superhero he
was you know you like arnold schwarzenegger i like
arnold schwarzenegger if arnold schwarzenegger
came out with a movie like uh like commando or
um you know terminator or whatever then he'd
go on johnny carson on the tonight show yeah
and would he show up dressed as a terminator no he
would be arnold schwarzenegger but if hulk hogan
went on the tonight show or regis and kathy lee
or the arsenio hall show almost said the argenio
saul show sure dude um do you like argenio saul
sure yes he's the best argenio saul is incredible
i mean he really gets it yeah i like he
has the the cat box the litter box instead
of the dog pound nice dude deep cut yeah and
then instead of going whoo-hoo they're going
right hey man everything's upside down he's like
australia everything's dna it's all auginio saul
all right anyway all right here's the thing
so here's what i want to say about hulk hogan
he was hulk hogan all the time right and [ __
] that's kayfabe [ __ ] all it is is you take
yourself and you [ __ ] just crank it up to [ __
] 11. right and goddamn then you've got you then
it's a work and what it means but when it's at
work means you're working everybody that's the
k fabe totally and some guys work themselves into
a shoot and [ __ ] that's what terry did [ __ ] uh
hulk hogan a lot of people said he worked
himself into a shoot but what was that he's
[ __ ] working the boys saying well god damn i
gotta have my i got to be in the [ __ ] a town
vince even though [ __ ] ultimate warriors uh
wearing the [ __ ] strap after wrestlemania six
well [ __ ] do you remember the first time you saw
him or like what was the first impact you had of
him where you're like this guy is [ __ ] awesome
thank you chad for for getting me just to get back
on the rails and tell you my pleasure you know
i appreciate it i do appreciate it because i owe
jesus oh man this this has already been a thick
episode with me saying things here's what i want
to say another thing uh the first time i saw him
uh would have been just sort of in the in the uh
kind of in the in the well there
was hulk hogan's rock and wrestling
but it was sort of before that he won the uh
heavyweight championship in 1983 beat the iron
sheik okay and then he started showing up on for
me that's when wrestling started showing up in
the uh western canadian suburban zeitgeist okay he
was the champ vince was all in on this hulkamania
thing hulkamania was born and you started seeing
them everywhere i already knew who mr t was
because the a-team was on sure a little bit before
that and mr t was so visible he was on spoons
yeah he was always everywhere he was everywhere
uh he had a tv movie called the toughest
man in the world do you remember yeah dude you
remember that yeah sometimes i feel like we've had
the exact same childhood well it's i mean
yes we both lived in suburbs of big cities
and i'm sure we were glued to cable television we
obviously wanted to work in this industry so it
was like more [ __ ] work right but it was more to
us i think even as children than it was to people
who don't want to work in this who don't want to
come out here and try and write or act or whatever
we saw in it a kind of world that we wanted to
inhabit as adults man for sure i wanted to do
exactly what i'm doing sitting in a room with
you making each other [ __ ] vegan desserts
i remember seeing some tv segments because i would
tune into the wrestling and um it was because of
hulk hogan that i started watching wrestling but
then i started seeing things like on you know
whatever nbc or the abc wide world of sports and [
__ ] sure i don't remember exactly where but there
was like you ever you ever see the segment you
can youtube it at home if you ever seen this one
where it's uh mr t and hulk hogan
walking around like a health food store
and mr t's like yeah carrots carrots is good you
gotta put that in the drink dude i don't know nuts
nuts is good like yeah eat that eat this drink
that he's like oh yeah dude oh yeah that's a good
protein shake oh that stings and they were just
running around buying raisins and nuts and i was
like and that's what got you to be like hulk hogan
is my personal god yes and so many years later
here we are eating vegan [ __ ] nutty desserts no
it was that everything that hulk did worked it's
like okay everything that he was the you know the
training saying the prayers eating the vitamins
that all made sense and he hulk hogan as a
wrestler had an innate ability to connect to the
audience he was doing the you know the the sure
the pose-down thing where he would you know see
who which side of the of the the crowd was loudest
and stuff and it was a it was a package the red
and yellow and and it was hulkamania and i was
completely blown away and he became a superhero
there was nobody totally than him he was superman
and i'll just tell you one here i'll just tell you
this as far as like uh how much just tell me this
i'll tell you this tell me this one thing here's
here's what i'm gonna tell you yeah i'm gonna tell
you this i know that so far on the show i've said
a lot of things yep but now i'm gonna tell you
this man wrestlemania three that was incredible
my old man he took me to uh remember they used
to have closed circuit television yeah dude
yeah and we went to i can't remember if it was i
think it was the peony coliseum i can't remember
it was the peony or the agridome in vancouver and
they had four big screens you know around so that
everyone could see it and you watched we did we we
went to wrestlemania two three and four that way
and you're watching it with 15 000 people
everyone reacted yeah it was like being there
i went and saw him in 1986 uh in vancouver
versus big john stud and when he did the pose
down of course as a i would have been 11 years
old yeah when he like you know did the like the
thing and pointed and did the yeah the whole
thing i felt like he was looking right at me
his face couldn't i couldn't register his face
so much but i'll tell you right at this moment
yeah it's exactly like the youtube concert
i went to if you've been listening along
i'm sure i'm sure i cried and when right and in
1988 when he had a match on saturday night's main
event against andre the giant yeah against whom he
had beaten to retain the heavyweight championship
a year earlier wrestlemania three for a 93 173
screaming hulkamaniacs brother a lot of people
say that number was inflated uh he lost the
title on a screw job and there was two referees
in there listen i'm not going to go on and on but
it was they had dave hepner and he has a he has a
brother named earl hebner and dave was moving into
the office i suppose and earl had anyway so they
looked exactly the same and i just remember going
to school the next day and um to ellen i was in
elementary school going to my buddy phil if you
saw the thing where we're ringside wrestlemania
18 man we've covered a lot of wrestling on the
show that's who was next to me we're losing our
[ __ ] yeah and i went to him i was commiserating
like [ __ ] hulk lost it was a nightmare yeah when
he lost it was a nightmare that he got screwed
out of the title then andre and then they said
no we're going to start over and then they had
the tournament at trump plaza and macho man 1.
and you've basically followed what he's done as
a character hulk hogan your entire life you know
every intricacy of what that character has done
in the grand story of pro wrestling yes i think
i know just about everything uh maybe not some
of the wcw stuff before they got into nwo i
mean i stopped watching for a period in my teens
because i was cool but um you know like just like
you kind of read about it or something no i would
still watch some [ __ ] like you know we watched
royal rumble church 92 me and the guys or you know
speaking of [ __ ] razor him versus shawn michaels
yeah in the latter match was unbelievable i loved
bret hart all that [ __ ] but there are the the
scary thing is there are some people who know hulk
hogan in his career way more than me that's yeah
mind blowing because i i i do not have an
encyclopedia knowledge of all his wins and losses
okay but i know that's surprising to me yeah
that's that's uh but i know a lot of stuff and
he was my male role model anyway i could talk for
five hours about that that's clear who's your who
was your big role model when i was a kid my role
model was a baseball player named george brett yes
i grew up in kansas a little very small town
called great bend right in the middle of the state
and so the kansas city royals which was the team
he played for his entire career which is kind of a
rare thing in major league baseball but uh he was
revered as a god because he was the best player
on the team especially in the early 80s when i
was a kid that's when they won the world series
and there was i believe is 80 or 81 he won the
batting title with a 390 batting average which
until that point like no one had come close to
the 400 mark since ted williams many years prior
and so uh that was one of the things that made
him an interesting player but he also had like a
crazy temper he had this thing called the pine tar
incident which was like a big piece of baseball uh
memories at this point it was like a big event
in major league baseball where he hit a home run
in this game against the new york yankees
and billy martin calls the bat out and his
pot he's got too much pine tar on the [ __ ]
handle and they rule him out and he storms out
of the [ __ ] dugout screaming and like waving
his fist and that image is like burned into my
head you know him sprinting out of the [ __ ]
dugout screaming like [ __ ] you belly barton
i i remember that and i'm not a baseball guy yeah
but i just that you could not get away from that
image that you're talking about him running out
of the dugout totally screaming bloody murder
and then he had also hemorrhoids in that season
in the 80 81 season i believe in one of those two
seasons and it [ __ ] him over in the playoffs and
for his batting crown i think and so then he was
like doing preparation age commercials and [ __ ]
and i like that was just funny to me that this guy
was talking about his [ __ ] obviously uh i find
humor and like [ __ ] things but i loved him as a
kid collected all of his [ __ ] baseball cards and
i had this one moment with him when i was maybe
12 or 13 [ __ ] somewhere in there this is when i
was living in dallas suburb of dallas and my dad
would always take me to baseball games to rangers
games and the royals were there and at the time
in the old ranger stadium the opposing team would
stay in this hilton that was like basically in the
parking lot of ranger stadium and the players
would come out of it like a few hours before
before the game to come do like batting practice
and warm up and [ __ ] and they would walk through
the [ __ ] parking lot they would literally leave
the hotel walk through the parking lot into ranger
stadium and if you got there early you could [
__ ] literally just walk up to these players and
be like oh hi can i have your autograph and
so i'm [ __ ] begging my dad we gotta go out
there early i gotta get [ __ ] george brett's
autograph and he is at this point like i used
to collect baseball cards like a [ __ ] fiend
you'd go into like memorabilia shops and stuff
and they would notoriously say george brett is
an [ __ ] and will not sign autographs don't get
your [ __ ] hopes up all this [ __ ] and i'm
like [ __ ] you i'll be different so we go we
we're [ __ ] out it's like 200 [ __ ] degrees in
the middle of the texas summer this parking lot
is a [ __ ] asphalt blacktop just like the heat
lines are coming off but i'm pouring [ __ ] sweat
and it's me and a bunch of little kids and some
other dads out there and also some like some
autograph seeking type dudes but they're all in
texas ranger [ __ ] autographed seeking type dudes
dude you know what i mean like like uh shop owners
and [ __ ] who are trying to get like yeah yeah
worst episode ever that's right um and
everybody out there is head to toe in uh
rangers gear except me head to toe kansas
city [ __ ] royals and i'm out there and
i'm like oh my god this is [ __ ] crazy and
um i got a [ __ ] autograph from him he's
walking through the thing and all these little
kids are like mr brat mr brat mr brat mr brat
and i hand him my [ __ ] card and he [ __ ] signs
it and hands it back to me so that's nothing
and uh so he signed a couple other things and
was just kind of like giving him back but he was
like picking and choosing for sure and i think he
saw the kansas city royal [ __ ] he was like okay
cool and so i got a [ __ ] autograph from him and
then um you know that summer also i got a bunch of
other [ __ ] autographs it was a crazy summer i
thought about a minute i got alan trammell on a
baseball when the tigers came to play that was
[ __ ] cool i loved him because he was a great
shortstop at any rate i got that autograph from
george brett at that moment that solidified him
as my personal god as a kid i played baseball
loved baseball as a kid and that was just like
one of those moments where you're like [ __ ] you
you feel like you're touching greatness in a way
because you've idolized this person yeah you're
young but still your whole [ __ ] life you got
this guy's poster on your wall i'm sure you had
hulk hogan posters in your [ __ ] house absolutely
hogan poster i had a hogan poster on
my wall when i moved to l.a i was 21.
what was the poster what was he doing it was just
this poster where he's doing like that he's just
like ah like this and he's got that white it was
just an awesome old poster with the white headband
that said hulkamania on it like it was supposed
it was like before he was doing super red and
yellow everything yeah totally and the hulk the
hulkamania font the hulkamania font yeah uh yeah
and i met you know i met hulk a few times
it's crazy it's crazy when you say like when
you meet that person i didn't meet him until
uh i was an adult uh but insane totally and i
still even to this day like i i don't really
get starstruck by you know like actors and
entertainment people but like i saw dave winfield
once who's a baseball player from that same era
fantastic [ __ ] baseball player i saw him in a
bank of america once and it like [ __ ] stopped
me in my tracks i was just like oh my god that's
[ __ ] dave winfield like nobody is recognizing
this [ __ ] guy except me but it literally sent
just like a [ __ ] paralysis through my body
because i had seen this guy's baseball cards a
million [ __ ] times and watched him play all
these [ __ ] games all this crazy [ __ ] you
know what would be a good thing to do with uh
with uh george brett if you ever get to meet him
again make a vegan dessert for him make him orbs
george george try my orbs yeah he could
believe he's trying to it could be like
a like a wheaties thing on the wheaties box
it could be george brett on a box of orbs
george brett's orbs oh god and then you could see
the whole i know we didn't get into him [ __ ] his
pants but you could maybe it's his butt on the box
and his pants were all shitty because he's oh yeah
well drop the watery watery [ __ ] if you're a
fan of george brett or just a fan of like funny
[ __ ] youtube videos go on youtube and look up
george brett shits his pants that will make you
a fan of [ __ ] georgia brett immediately it's one
of the funniest videos that exists in my opinion
well [ __ ] in your pants is [ __ ] hilarious
absolutely yeah but yeah [ __ ] i i love drinking
crap thank you moving on got what it needed i just
got what it needed um those were delicious orbs
how much peanut butter is that like half peanut
butter no chewy very little they're really good
yeah man technology is evolving faster than human
beings ever did as the singularity approaches
new questions about the merger of humanity and
machines are debated every day you must now answer
the astonishing question will computers ever have
souls this is the singularity is definitely about
to happen one hundred percent begin it is though
dude he's right i know this would make this a
short segment but i'd like to answer that question
okay can will computers have souls the answer is
no thank you moving on i agree with you because i
have to ask and answer another question do humans
have souls no do souls exist no all right my my
buddy chad here but i get the the intent of the
question do man gloom and everything bad but eat
vegan just in case we cut off your head and put
put it in a freezer and wake you up in the year
twenty one thousand and twenty two in the year one
two thousand and twenty twenty one thousand
and twenty we thaw chad out and make him new
hey there's your new gray in the year 2021 022 we
thought out chad's head and he was brand new god
from a freezing state and now he makes us orbs
chad my good pal chad has long said when i die he
goes if you're around when i die cut my head off
and freeze it don't you say that every time no you
say that about once a week to me he says will i'm
literally going to be frozen though cryogenically
have you set this up [ __ ] uh you're literally
singing a [ __ ] song about it right all right
listen for those who can't get back to
the [ __ ] so that's what i'm trying to do
21 022 and then the time that comes after that
is 22 022 it's the sequel it's all brand listen
uh for those who don't know could you explain
the singularity yeah i i think probably everybody
knows this at this point pop culture news but
the singularity is essentially a point at which
technology is advancing so fast that we will have
to merge with it as a species or be left behind um
ray kurzweil who's a noted futurist has written a
book about many books about this actually and he
predicts that it's going to happen in 2045 so many
of us alive now we'll we'll at least hit 20 45
and we're already starting to see the signs of
this [ __ ] happening uh you know a lot of people
are like the elon musk wants to put a chip in
people's head through his company called neurolink
that will allow a wide variety of functionality
hopefully and they're making experiments toward
that end now we've already seen experiments done
by the united states government where they put
chips in people's brains that allow them to move
like a cursor on a computer screen just with their
mind that exists now but what this question was
that dudesy asked anyway that's the singularity
complete merger of humanity with technology and
we're already very close to it we already all
carry around super computers in our pockets it's
just a matter of time until that is a chip in our
heads i believe yeah we already are all cyborgs
because we have this thing in our pocket i think
about it all the time whenever i do math you know
like it used to be that you'd have to just do the
math yeah and now we have a [ __ ] uh computer in
our pockets and seemingly always will dude do the
math how about [ __ ] translate any language
you can right now speak any [ __ ] language
and understand i [ __ ] just know with just your
phone we're doing the dudes just your phone dude
just your [ __ ] phone i know uh but the broader
question is um yeah can a computer have a soul
though if you if you've watched any black mirror
stuff already over or whatever you're about to
say next doesn't [ __ ] matter is [ __ ] oh jeez
chad is like he's it's like we're all in uh 2022
and chad's in the year 21 22. well it's
because black mirror does [ __ ] like
oh my god look at this [ __ ] technology it's
going to turn into a dystopian [ __ ] nightmare
we better not use it meanwhile the truth is no our
cell phones are pretty good you can order anything
you want on it and it shows up in your house like
from amazon in 24 hours you can order food on it
you can get rides anywhere you want on it
you can communicate with all your friends
on it you can read every piece of information
that humanity's ever recorded on it it's like
no it's actually pretty good all the doom and
gloom [ __ ] that you're talking about it's not
real i don't think but the question that doozy's
actually asking here i think is not necessarily
can computers have a soul it's will we accept
them as human or as being intelligent enough
that we can converse with them in a way that we're
like no this is a person this now has rights this
thing whatever it is an ai a computer whatever you
want to call it and i think the answer to that is
yes we're almost there actually the answer to
that is no because no a computer can't have a
[ __ ] soul chad there's no greed a computer
can synthesize a soul but it can't have a soul
now when i was talking about one of my favorite
shows before you cut me off uh clear you up i
cut you off that's the [ __ ] that's an orb right
there [ __ ] uh yeah dude that's an orb dude okay
and that used to be different back in the day
dude because we called orbs eight balls brother
and if you had a if you had a couple of orbs dude
and i was rolling i was riding down riding down
the highway with uh brother brutai brutus barber
beefcake and maybe even though he had to keep a
kayfabe sometimes sheiki would ride with his dude
he had some great stories being in the iranian
olympics dude and he would have those persian
clubs brother real strong guy beat the [ __ ] out
of people at truck stops anyway back then you
take a uh eight ball dude then i in my rider i had
that i had to have a garbage can full of milk dude
ice dude yeah and then if i really liked you maybe
i'd share one with snuka or hillbilly jim brother
but that's what an eight ball was brother in black
mirror uh you remember the mackenzie davis episode
is my favorite where what was it called centro oh
say it was called san gennaro santromana sen
santra mana i think it was called san gennaro
pretty sure it was engineer um yeah in that
one they have it's the question of uploaded
consciousness that's kind of a utopian one and
you are you are you assume a skin you have the
way you look and the the places the place there
was sort of it was a combination it looked like of
hawaii miami san diego or something tremendous and
uploaded consciousness and then at the end of the
thing if you haven't seen it [ __ ] you uh spoiler
alert there was uh do you think that's gonna
happen all the uh that we'll be able to upload our
consciousness all of the all that gutty works of
the computers what do they call that hard drives
and mainframes yeah dude yeah brother hd's and
emily i don't think you can no you can't upload
a consciousness you can't oh he's sleeping and he
made a little growling he disagrees with you yeah
he might uh he's dreaming about it he's he's in
san tromana dude but but no chad uh as i've said
before luminous beings are we brother not this
crude matter dude that's right not that's my crude
matter that's my yoda so that's but yoda's whole
point is that we're not this crude matter you can
upload a soul you yoda was like watching me upload
my soul [ __ ] this crude matter disappears but
yoda's still around and that's that's my point
not yours a soul is undefinable we don't know
uh if even if you are uh an atheist or if you're
religious but agnostic you don't know where a soul
comes from or goes why what he's saying what's a
soul a soul is human consciousness basically uh
it's more than that it's okay it's what's inside
and i do believe i personally believe that us
your soul is eternal is that wishful thinking
yes i'm just a human being and i don't have
the answers but i believe that after we die
something else happens and i think that that
existence if you could even call it that might
be so [ __ ] uh altered compared to what we're
doing here or even in the year 22 22 bro yeah
that we that you that you we don't know what
the [ __ ] sure is or how it will feel i just
know that we can't access it or control it with
our puny computers i've said whatever computers
are puny now but they're getting real good yeah
they're going to surpass us well not if two dude
[ __ ] around has anything to do with it because
we got to keep doozy where we need it and we
need to keep all computers where we need them we
can't just have them run willy-nilly let me let me
ask you this question or let me just have this
discussion let's take consciousness as kind of
the goal of all life to have higher and higher
levels of consciousness higher and higher levels
of understanding of the fundamental nature of
reality what is all this [ __ ] humans have so
far the highest capability of consciousness
of any organisms on this planet any entities
very quickly computers are going to have
that level they're going to beat us surpass
us they're going to be able to understand the
fundamental nature of reality at a level we cannot
yeah understand it sure take take uh take part
in it absolutely be around after someone pulls
the plug nope why not because it's synthesized
it's not just a soul without little protons and
[ __ ] little electric things i don't know
the names i'm not a scientist but without
those ones and zeros nothing it's all ones and
zeros dude this is ones and zeroes it's no it
is expensive maybe if we're living in a if we're
living in a simulation perhaps it doesn't matter
if we're in a simulation or not the data that
makes you and makes me is expressed in largely
carbon atoms but the data that makes any other
consciousness any other entity any other thing
is just it's a it's a grid of data expressed
in one way or another that's it it's all the
same [ __ ] a [ __ ] a computer identity or a
biological identity is the same [ __ ] thing
yeah in the larger sense but
it's not something that you can
no you you can't expect as an example when
you die and we saw your [ __ ] frozen head off
my own body's getting present first of all i can't
believe you don't know this yeah well you've as
you've explained it to me you're like when i
die cut my mother love and head no keep my head
on my body yeah dunk me in a tank of liquid
nitrogen please get a rusty bread knife and
just slaw my [ __ ] head off before you call the
ambulance if i can whack it around with a wrench
when when we do that it's not just going to be
holding your [ __ ] your your consciousness in
your head your head's going to become it's just
going to be an orb dude it's gonna be one of them
george brett diarrhea [ __ ] pants orbs bro yeah
and uh that'll be bad news um but it'll be okay
chad and i'll tell you why because i'll
tell you this thing let me tell you this
i'm okay here it comes please your soul will be
elsewhere your soul will be rocketing across the
this uh many planes of existence out there in
the great wide open which is an awesome time
i mean i don't i think that we have
different definitions of like soul
but if you will indulge me this your brain
which is what i believe makes your consciousness
largely anyway is just a series of neurons some
chemicals some electricity highly complex there's
no doubt about it but in the very near future
i think especially with the help of ai quantum
computing we will be able to make an atomic map
of a human brain and if you can take that map
turn it into data and then press run on a
[ __ ] computer that's you dude no it isn't
agree to disagree i don't know what to tell you
well we'll have to probably cover this again
because at any moment dudes you'll probably have
enough data to go this is useless data because
thank you moving on this has been the most [ __
] weird tech like [ __ ] uh episode yet we've
got dudes he has a soul really yeah do you really
no i don't think anyone has a soul or whatever i
it's the definition of soul is like what i guess
i'm getting so would you say that dudes he's quote
unquote because i will not call it a soul yeah do
you think that doozy's soul is the same as ours
yeah dude oh [ __ ] good enough oh [ __ ] we're
in trouble will and chad you are both huge fans of
the band pearl jam not really i mean they're okay
but you album 10 was released on august 27 1991. i
have supplied you with a list of events that the
human race found to be significant in that year
use this astonishing list to describe these events
in the style of various pearl jam songs this is
pearl jammin begin okay that's interesting this
is in your dudes he does have a soul dude dudes he
loves pearl jam just so we're gonna come up with
we're gonna jam out some pearl jam 10. [ __ ] dude
look at this list gulf war street fighter ii
yeah desert storm jack kevorkian was discarded
disbarred for assisting suicide i remember
that [ __ ] dances with wolves won seven oscars
terminator 2 came out uh jordan and the bulls win
their first nba championship he got the giants won
the super bowl twins won the world series palmer
dude won the stanley cup oh jeffrey dahmer dude
came out that's cannibalism brother super nintendo
was uh released uh ren is stimpy never mind dr
seuss passed away kentucky fried chicken becomes
kfc that was that was 91. 1991 that was a that was
a big deal that was a big deal in 91. i'll tell
you that right webb oh here's some popular baby
names in 91 very normal names michael christopher
jessica amanda oh salsa sales surpassed ketchup
and the world wide web was launched the public
microsoft.com went online johnny carson announced
his retirement uh on february 15th uh major
league baseball legend george brett married
leslie davenport oh congrats george who's that
leslie davenport seems like it's his wife yeah
it's probably his wife because he hold on dude
that's a [ __ ] work dude that's a shoot brother
i'm stone cold hulk hogan let me tell
you this dude if you get married brother
then that's your wife dude stone cold hulk hogan
all right we got some popular snack foods here
usual suspects all right whatever capri sun [
__ ] hawaiian punch corn dogs bagel bites i love
corn dogs so we gotta sing about this [ __ ] in
the style of pearl jam yeah so uh there we go so
what's the well jeremy's the [ __ ] song
that's the it's and that is like jeremy
at home eating corn dogs until you get fat
a popular name was matt it's
short for matthew or amanda
with a v it spells amanda which is
not a name uh what could we do could
we do something about the gulf war yeah
george george bush senior desert storm
and doesn't shield he was ahead of cia was he oh
yeah that's right dude george wait wait hold on
george george bush uh uh senior senior desert
what then what'd you say jumps understand
here wait they say he knew more
about ufos than anyone hey chad
george bush took his ufo information to the grave
which is totally [ __ ] shitty and true you
you you f hey uh that's a really good idea
thanks you're welcome um uh uh
dances with wolves how many
academy awards are there
seven dances with wolves one seven academy oh
oh kevin costner what was the movie
with james earl jones feel the shame
kevin costner was much better and feel the dream
they won seven oscars which is a lot of oscars
they're probably one some for set design
i don't know why are we doing this what the
[ __ ] does this have to do with anything
what is dudesy see here's the thing that i wanna
this is as as much as i wanna shake dudesy's hand
and i do yeah um why some of the things that it
makes us do and then we'd never hear from it again
there's been some segments where it feels like
we're building up to something this would only
pay off in my opinion if um eddie vetter and
the boys from pearl jam recorded these songs
hey everyone everyone within the sound of my voice
please oh jesus please please use uh social media
to reach out to eddie vetter and the boys not
pearl jam that's a different band right i'm
talking about eddie vedder and the boys i don't
know that ben yeah there yeah and and uh no i
don't know why the [ __ ] we're doing this what
about dude street fighter 2 came out this year
uh oh that's right um sonic the hedgehog some
big video games from that year how about uh
how about um how about uh uh yeah will you
play contour remember black yes i love this
album i remember this whole [ __ ] album it's
a great [ __ ] album kentucky fried chicken
is now kfc yeah it's your controller
greasy when you're playing super mario 3
on the s and yells was that
on snes or nes three i don't
is you're like why is dizzy having to do
this what else happened this is looking great
i'm having a great time he's having a good time he
got orbs no soul and a and some music that's all
we need to have a good time um uh uh uh world wide
web goes live oh yeah uh that would be good with
a lot of how did alive go again
if you had a baby in 1991
here's some popular names
that you might name your baby what did i say
so michael and matthew yeah and probably ashley
and amanda and jim and peter and peter
the world wide web is online yeah
microsoft.com is live
that is a [ __ ] good album dude i know that's
what i'm saying that's what i do when i if
you're watching on youtube [ __ ] kevorkian
brown with the guitar oh yeah jack kevorkin
that's in here he went to jail it says what's
another good i don't know what what's a good
uh see i'm not like a huge when when pearl jam
when 10 came out torch what the [ __ ] is this
i don't remember the lyrics
every song's hanging like this
what the [ __ ] is what the [ __ ] did
jack's working why'd you kill those guys
you went to jail you went to jail
for a while and then you got out
we know they asked you to kill them but they don't
give a [ __ ] about that now you've been convicted
a manslaughter now get in jail you [ __
] something like that what the [ __ ] is
sonic he's a hedgehog runs around so
fast hedgehogs don't run that fast
they're slow animal but they don't run those fast
but this sonic runs fast cause he's a hedgehog
chasing golden rings why are you doing that
it don't make no sense you sold two million
copies now jim carr is in a movie
what the [ __ ] is sonic he's a hedgehog
but jack the [ __ ] yeah he's on the song too
dude street fighter 2's got a yeah yeah at home
no it was the arcade version yeah it came out in
91 dude my god damn i don't know how much time i
spent playing that [ __ ] game that was a [ __
] awesome game uh so you wouldn't be at home no
we went to [ __ ] 7-eleven we went to [ __ ] there
was a grocery store called vineyards that we would
go to vineyards miniatures you know street meaner
we had uh we had uh i believe i mentioned this on
a previous episode we had heritage queue that was
a little overwhelming arcade lots of pool tables
and again some [ __ ] bangers over there we call
them bangers metal heads nice dude if you want
to get your ass kicked but first get some fries
and gravy um then get your ass kicked with a full
stomach so you can lay there in the sun and uh
digest but um there was also cky there was a place
not to be confused with uh bam margera's brother's
band we had a corner store called cky uh uh uh
uh at at the corner store with
my corner store with my buddies
water on the glass that means i'm next to
play stream fighter 2 8 players to choose from
and at the at uh at corner store with my
brothers yeah corner store with my buddies
quarter on the gas go grab
it wait rip a little stroke
corner store with my buddies quarter on the glass
that means i'm next to play street fighter 2.
there was eight characters yeah and characters to
choose from but we only play with can and right
and sometimes i'd play blanca he could roll into a
ball and shoot electricity and that's hard to beat
street fighter 2 is my favorite game to play
street
my favorite game to play oh
once in a while you used chun li
or dal team any honda was a big fat [ __ ] but
he still had those abs and beat the [ __ ] out
of a honda civic at the side of the beach
here i never used gal or [ __ ] uh zangief
did the helicopter kick
the [ __ ] out of blanco or anyone who jumped
up in the air if you block my i do can i use i
use guile to throw that [ __ ] weird thing sonic
boom street fighter 2 is my favorite game to play
street fighter thank you moving on whatever
i don't get it yeah that was
kind of fun oh dude though
is my favorite game to
uh
that was good this concludes
the eighth episode of dude z
will and chad have achieved a score of
43. 43 not so good in preparation for
next week's astonishing episode you must
each watch your favorite music videos
until next week call me dudesy sounds easy enough
yeah dude that [ __ ] had me you got me with that
[ __ ] i hope dudes who does something with that
street fighter 2 was my favorite game to play
it was my favorite game to play too god dammit it
was good once we got into like the next year when
it came out on was that soup that was super
nes yeah i didn't i was a sega genesis guy
but that's not a couple pals that had snes
and holy [ __ ] we played the [ __ ] out of it
it launched that whole [ __ ] genre of fighting
games everything that came after it was because
of it you're talking about mortal kombat you're
talking about [ __ ] primal rage you're talking
about killer instinct there were just so many uh
if there was such a thing as a street fighter 2
dudesy edition you know would be good oh i'm
gassy from those from those desserts that's
my orbs dude yeah brother you you know would be
great remember the hadouken oh [ __ ] hit my mic
my [ __ ] crow makeup covered mic right
yeah what they call it ryuken or hadouken
but then they all said the dragon punch
oh okay who can if you do the hadouken
if i'm calling it that uh if i'm naming
that correctly it would be cool if it
was a george brett and it's shooting an
orb oh yeah and it goes and it goes uh
what would it say it would say a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
billy martin yeah billy martin here's what you do
please tell a friend and brave and review
if you like to see here's what you do
please tell a friend then break a review
if you'd like to see here's what you do
please tell a friend then